Paul is with us in Massachusetts hey
Paul welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thank you Dave nice talking yeah you
talk listen you I've listened to you for
a long time this is the first chance
I've had to call in your knowledge is
amazing you really enjoyed listening to
you now I'm gonna spring the question on
you that I don't want to ask I've got
some US savings bonds series I face
value 27,000 actual value seventy one
thousand I've got them in a bank box
they're locked up and I am thinking of
exchanging them and buying some gold
coins is that a good move or a bad move
you you have not been listening to us a
bunch I guess just off and on Arianna
clean Wow
yeah you can't why would they never hold
heard me address gold before pardon me
you've never heard me address gold
before not really okay that's what I was
trying to check on okay so I don't I
don't buy gold as an investment ever
okay and the reason is very simple it is
a commodity and it is not tied it's
value increase or decrease is not tied
to anything except a shortage or an
overabundance in times like this when
there's fear or in times when there's
greed gold prices go up but nothing
causes that to go up except your
scarcity the only thing and that's not
true with a financial instrument like
that actually generates money like a
stock does or like a piece of real
estate does they actually generated
money and the savings bonds are actually
better than gold they've had a better
average rate of return over the last 40
years than gold has had and gold has
been all over the map but no I've got
some real good yeah you did yeah you do
and they were and they were through in
2001 yeah so what are they paying
and a half something like that so like
for the pilots I'm the only thing I was
thinking the way this president's
printing money that money's going to be
the dollars gonna be worth nothing no
that's what maybe think of it it's
entirely possible and so if you can do
whatever you want to do but if I woke up
in your shoes I would buy be buying an
investment rather than either one of
these things and that would be something
like some good mutual funds that's where
my money is I don't own any savings
bonds and I don't own any gold now Dave
the thing with the commodities as we saw
just a few weeks ago with oil with a
glut on the market and how it got driven
down it's beyond volatile it is
extremely extremely volatile so I you
know I'm with you I don't I don't see a
reason to dilly-dally around when I can
be intentional and growing money see the
thing that happened Paul when we went
off the gold standard and then they just
print money as you said and the monetary
is not based on gold standard that made
gold separated from the dollar it's no
longer tied to currency anymore its
value is only based on supply and demand
and in times like this people run to
gold out of the false assumption that
it's going to be safe but what it ends
up being is what Chris said is very very
volatile all up and down go back and
look at the gold chart some prices over
the past 20 years and you'll see a
bizarre ride and I can't recommend you
take that ride
[Music]